في المقابله افاد مراسل عسكري موال لموسكو
بتقدم القوات الروسيه باتجاه سوليدار
ارتيموسك وتحرير قريه هناك بالقرب من
مدينه سولدار واضاف المراسل ان الهجوم
الروسي لا يزال مستمر من عده اتجاهات على
حد تعبيره وكاله وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
الجزيره طبعا
ازدهار وفقا لبياناتي هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه فان باخمد ما تزال محطه تركيز
القوات الروسيه التي تسعى ليسيطرت عليها
والهجوم
في المدينه القوات الاوكرانيه تقول ان
الهجمات تشل من الجهه الجنوبيه والجهه
الشرقيه اضافه الى محاولات للتقدم من
الجهه الشماليه الشرقيه حيث مدينه حيث
مدينه سوليدر كذلك القوات الاوكرانيه شرعت
في انشاء التعداد الخطوط الدفاعيه داخل
المدينه واستخدام العديد من التعزات
العسكريه اليها لانها تتوقع حدوث معركه
ربما تكون مشابهه لما حدث في
سوليدر في مسعد روسي للسيطره على هذه
المدينه ايضا قالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه زادت من
استخدامها للقوه الجويه والغارات الجويه
في ذلك المحور وايضا ذكرت وجود عدد كبير
من القوات لاحظته زياده في عدد القوات
الروسيه المهاجمه الحقيقه ازدهار وفقا
ايضا لمشاهدتنا ولبنات هيئه الاركان فانه
هناك تغيير في نمط الهجوم الروسي خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه الامر لما يقعد فقط
التركيز على جبهه واحده ومشاغله باقي
الجبهات بل وفقا لبياناتها الاركان
الاوكرانيه فان الجبهات تبدو بنفس الحده
بذات الحده في محاور مختلفه ومتباعده وليس
الامر اشغالا فقط اتحدث عن مدن الجنوب
افديتكم رينكا وايضا في محور نيورك في
الجهه الجنوبيه وحتى في المحاور التي كانت
القوات الاوكرانيه فيها هي المبادره تتحدث
عن صفاته وكريمينا القوات الاوكرانيه تقول
انها تلاقي همم الدفاع عن المسلمين من قبل
جانب الروسي لان هناك بعض الجولات هي
تبداها القوات الروسيه ضد القوات
الاوكرانيه ايضا ليس فقط في الشرق بل ايضا
في جبهه التي كانت
متوقفه لاشهر وفقا لبعض المراسلين
العسكريين همم الاوكران فان القوات
الروسيه تعتمد رستوبا موجات البشريه
الكبيره همم وبثت صورا لذلك لمحاولات اللي
تقدم من ذلك المحور والنجوم على الخطوط
الدفاعيه هذه القوات الاوكرانيه همم تلك
المنطقه ويعزى ذلك وفقا لبيانات سابقه
لقياده الاركان ان القوات الروسيه زادت من
عدد وحداتها وصل الى 280 وحده عسكريه
اضافه للاعتمادها على مقاتليفاجنر
المتمرثين في القتال بالنسبه لي مناطق
السيطره بعجاله ازدهار حتى الان البيانات
الاوكرانيه والتصريحات لا تتحدث عن الوضع
في في سوليدار بوجه الخصوص او حتى في
اوبتنا جنوبي ضخمود
هذه البلده القريبه من ضخمه تقول ان
العمليات العسكريه هناك مستمره وان كانت
مواقع مقربه ومحسوبه همم لصالح الجانب
الاوكراني تظهر سيطره القوات الروسيه
وقوات اتفاجنر على هذه المناطق اخيرا همم
حاكم مقاطعه تحدث عن سقوط جرحه في قصف
الروسيه على مناطق في الجنوب تركيز القصف
في الفتره الاخيره على مدينه كره خوفا
الواقعه جنوبي مقاطعه